bill you know I read through your letter
over over the weekend and what I noticed
in the tone was that you are very
optimistic you say look we are better
off than we were decades ago where does
this optimism come from well I think I'm
naturally optimistic but also I think
the facts are on the side of the
optimist and I think it's actually
dangerous that people are focusing on
the bad news and not seeing the progress
we've made it means they don't look at
the best practices they it makes them
less generous we are raising poor
countries up most people live in
middle-income countries now there's more
to be done on health and agriculture but
the track record of success if you don't
see that you're you're not going to
participate what what we need to do and
you say that there will be no poor
nations by the time we reach 2035 almost
none landlocked countries in Africa in a
North Korea they don't change the
government but it'll be less than 10
which when I was born almost all
countries were poor now we're down to
about a quarter of them so the next 20
years if we focus on it we can make it
really really exceptional as you
mentioned in your letter you know not
everyone should have the luck of the
ovarian lottery which is what warren
buffett has talked about Mike you know
you donated last year about a hundred
million dollars to the Bill Gates
Foundation to fight to eradicate polio
from from this world do you share the
same optimism as bill yeah I couldn't be
more in agreement I think one of the
things people miss is that advocates
seldom want to acknowledge success
because they always want to have more to
do raise more money be more important
but builds a hundred percent right there
are a few people starving few people
sleeping without a roof over their head
fewer people that are illiterate life
expectancy is generally longer you know
by any rational measure things are
better now that doesn't mean every place
or every person and they'll always be a
bottom 20% will always redefine the what
the bottom 20% means but to say that all
of the foreign aid and
all of the monies for example that the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation or
Bloomberg or lots of other generous
people have invested it hasn't done
anything that's just not not true at all
we have a guy Tony Harry's a doctor in
Africa who's trying to get numbers and
find out what people are dying from
because if you can't measure it you
can't manage it you can't fix it and we
don't know a lot of times you look at
birth certificates it'll say act of God
well that doesn't tell you where you
want to put your money to save people's
lives but Bill and Melinda working on
polio this is the chance of really
eradicating this disease like smallpox
or both of us working on malaria or
things like vitamin A deficiency that
cost half a million people to go blind
permanently every year there's an awful
lot of new science new ways of
distributing in progress why do you
think the Mike that people don't want to
admit that there is that success well
number one we always see a few people
and you have to put it in context and
unless you have to step back and look at
the big picture you know we're talking
about eradicating something or changing
something when there's six or so billion
people on the planet the twenty five
people that you interact with during the
course of the day is hardly
representative and there are these old
beliefs that you're wasting your money
with this or that and that's just not
true and I think one of the great things
about Bill and Melinda is they never
shied a way of taking on the impossible
tasks and it turns out that complex
problems don't have simple answers if
they did they would have been solved but
the complex problems aren't unsolvable
either so what's going to be the
catalyst to change people's mind because
you you want to debunk these myths right
foreign aid is a waste for instance or
that poor people poor countries will
stay poor what is going to be the
catalyst to change people's perceptions
fundamentally well I think we want
people to spread the word it people
should feel great about the arrow of
time and but feel bad that we're not
doing more and headlines in a way or
what mislead you because bad news is a
headline and gradual improvement is not
and so when do we celebrate reduction in
malaria deaths when do we celebrate
P growth we almost have to take a letter
like this and speak out and say wait a
minute
despite how bad we feel about what's not
yet done we have some approaches that
work and the cynicism is holding us back
people who think a lot of a ghost
corruption they also think Aid is a big
part of the budget it's less than 1% but
if you ask people they'll say 25% or
certainly above 10% well in one of the
myths about about foreign aid or one of
the perceptions as you say is that you
know so much aid goes to governments
let's say in Africa and that they waste
that aid or that it gives corrupt
regimes of a pass to not doing the
things that they need to do what do you
say to that well historically during the
Cold War there was a lot of money that
was labeled aid that was really
friendship money to make sure the bad
guy was our bad guy versus the Soviets
bad guy and so nobody expected that the
human lives would improve dramatically
there now we don't have that agenda now
we can go in and say what will this do
for nutrition what will this do for kids
to fully develop physically and mentally
and help these countries be
self-sufficient and so many have
graduated from aid in Mexico Brazil that
now we're you know focusing on the tough
cases
but with the right vaccines the right
seeds and philanthropists coming in with
their businesslike mentality that Mike
and I have I think every year we're
going to be smarter about how we do it
also when you have big problems when you
say you solve them that doesn't mean you
got a hundred percent of them you know
if you have we brought smoking down in a
good part of this world dramatically
that'll save an enormous number of lives
having said that there's also places
where the smoking industry has managed
to get poor people who don't know that
it's bad for their health to increase
their rate of smoking are you making
progress yes should you be disappointed
no should you walk away from it not at
all and the Gates Foundation in
Bloomberg we work together to try to
that's one of the biggest killers the
smoking will kill a billion people this
century
but we've made progress and you have to
admit that and you have to look at what
works and if you're not willing to
acknowledge what works you're not going
to be able to know how to go help others
have you been surprised though at the
turnaround in the public view on issues
like smoking and issues like obesity for
instance and even now marijuana the
legalization of marijuana and how
rapidly people's perceptions have
changed about this well we still have a
long ways to go but if you take a look
these companies like the tobacco
companies target those that don't know
don't have the information don't have
the infrastructure or the history or
doctors locally who can give them advice
as to how to improve their lives and
extend the lies and so much of the
tragedy in this world is self-inflicted
it's not there are Wars there are as
genocide there's starvation and people
getting shot all the time but most of
the people die before they should
because of their own behavior and that's
what we have to work on educating them
giving them the tools explaining and
counteracting the special interests who
make money by selling them products or
getting them to do things that are
dangerous to themselves what about
cities Mike and their role well cities
aware you distribute services federal
governments and state governments tend
to move monies around cities are where
you pick up the garbage where you
educate the kids where you bring down
crime where you enact health measures
that you can actually see what you can
buy how its labeled where you can use it
those kinds of things and I think if you
take a look at most of the progress
that's been made in climate change for
example has all been done at the city
level very little is then even in this
country when we're fighting guns when
fighting obesity we're trying to improve
the school systems and bring down crime
those are not done at the federal state
level those really are done at the city
level bill you know I've always wanted
to know know this from you you have such
a huge arsenal both of you have a huge
arsenal of resources how do you pick the
causes that you get behind well globally
I think the greatest inequity is how
poor children don't get to grow up and
achieve their potential they die or they
simply don't have enough
food that their brain develops and so
we've decided that most of the money is
going to go to that cause unfortunately
there are things like new vaccines that
will help those kids avoid them getting
sick and we're seeing the progress you
know 5% of kids now die before the age
of five the prediction is we can get
that down to 1.6 percent and match where
the United States was in in 1980 and so
it's it's it's because it's this
injustice because a lot of these things
weren't being done at the level they
should be and once you pick an area you
develop expertise you go out and see the
people and you know that that's are
going to be our lifeline work but did
someone someone trigger you you know to
think about this area or was it just
something that lifelong evil I think he
listens to his wife Melinda has a lot of
good ideas for example maternal health
that's really all her bag and we've been
doing a number of things under her
guidance and to try to advance the
causes of getting the kids so they can
get born and survive the first couple
days and then the next five years and
but there's lots of good ideas and you
just have to look you can't do
everything you have to decide what your
core competencies are whether you want
to do it internally and like the Bill
and Melinda foundation in a lot of cases
they administer funds and in other cases
they give funds in our case we'd
probably do more in meant of donating
funds and having others administer it
but we have a big group that's working
on a lot of the public health issues
internally as well well Mike when you
were mayor I mean you had very certain
you had certain metrics by which you
could measure the success of your of
your own project and initiative so when
you give money how do you measure
success well number one not everything
is going to work quickly so you have to
have some patience number two if you do
something and in the scientific world
and it turns out to be a failure that in
some sense is a success because you
don't have to go down that path again
unfortunately in the world I came from
you're labeled a failure and it's all
wasted your money right that's not the
case the way science works and so
knowing what you're doing measuring it
and there are a lot of people around who
are trying to a
apply metrics in some cases you can in
some cases you just have to do it on
faith I know down the road this is going
to help and I'm willing to make that bet
and then wait a little while give it the
old college try if it doesn't work don't
be stubborn but don't walk away from it
too quickly either how about you bill
well each project got to come in with a
commitment like our smoking groups come
in and talk us about how we're going to
get the prevalence down Mike's group has
led the way on that and it's going very
very well
e we back in science area we back a lot
of different scientists so even if you
know one approach fails if it's an
important problem then we've got three
or four it's a portfolio type approach
and the successes you have like we've
had some new seeds where the farming
productivity is doubled that gives you
the belief to just keep trying because
you get to go out to the countries and
actually meet the people who are growing
more rice than they ever did before well
with the private money I mean you do
have that luxury of as you say Mike that
you can experiment you can see what
works and if it doesn't work you move on
to it or you can do a lot of things with
private money you cannot do with public
money my daughter works with a group of
people a Robin Hood Foundation and they
try a lot of new things their interest
is local education and that sort of
thing but if we didn't have private
money you'd still have the old masters
because government would have said I
wouldn't invest in Impressionism that's
not our it's the private monies that
have true history have been willing to
try new things have an instinct that
something is going to work where they
can't prove it but are willing to make
that bet and that's how progress is made
now you two are old friend and you work
together but you're also you're also
very good personal friends I know Mike
you're going to be heading off to Africa
soon right
it's part of a global mayor's conference
and Bill you've been to Africa numerous
numerous times in your in your
foundations work what advice you have
for Mike when he goes to Africa what do
you think he should see there well my
wife Melinda and daughter spending the
week there out on a farm getting down to
see these projects is a
citing Mike's been super generous on
malaria research so I hope you'll feel
good going in and seeing that the death
rate is down seen what more has to be
done in talking to the people on the
ground there about which tools are hard
to deliver which are easy to deliver you
know Africa is fantastic the cities need
a lot of help the scientific research
needs a lot of help and that's why we're
more and more of our philanthropy will
help those countries that that have
great needs one of the places that
Melinda is has 50,000 people per doctor
in America we have 500 people for doctor
there are places there where there are
no roads so that if you need an
operation emergency operation you just
die and we've been training people to do
appendectomy and caesareans which turn
out to be relatively simple operations
but without that everybody that needed
one of those is not going to survive and
yet with a little help working you're
not going to cure everything you're not
going to be able to do open-heart
surgery but you can do a few things and
that can make an enormous difference and
save countless lives what do you hope to
do there to see there accomplish in
Africa well the the organization that
I'm participating in is a group of 63
cities that focus on climate change
sharing best practices and that sort of
thing but they all have the same
problems they all have to educate and
protect and improve the health of people
and all through Africa and the Latin
America and all of them in Asia and
Europe and America we all have very
similar problems some of them are of
different magnitudes some have involved
different diseases but you don't have to
go very far from right where we're
sitting just go to Haiti and look at the
terrible tragedy that's taking place
there the world pledged all this money
and yet they're still there with
diseases that I thought were eradicated
and living in tents and not having the
ability to be in charge of their own
destiny and feed their families and
we've just got to get together and do
things about it you know many people
watching this interview our big admirers
of your work I'm curious to know who you
admire are their thought leaders that
you look up to well we learned from each
other we've actually are both
early members of a group called The
Giving Pledge for a lot of plants but
sit and share mistakes you know there's
people like George Soros who has done
really innovative work we get to meet
the scientists work on this stuff maybe
the most amazing are the people out in
the field who you know spend big parts
of their life in Africa taking these
tools that we helped back and making
sure they get out there they're also I
think you have to separate people's
political interests from their
willingness to help there are some soros
is clearly liberal i think it's a fair
ways to say the Koch brothers clearly
very conservative but the Koch brothers
are given enormous money to different
hospitals and try to improve what they
give them credit for that
yeah I mean you'll have to agree with
everything everybody does but I don't
know if I agree with you the side of
those two but but I think that they all
deserve credit and it's just an awful
lot of people and also there are a lot
of people who aren't billionaires who
aren't even millions who write small
checks or give their time and go out
there and work and Lobby their elected
officials to take government money and
try to improve the health of everybody
and they deserve an enormous amount of
credit as well well maybe that seeds in
also to build what you were talking
about with these mr. Shep for
misperception is some people feel that
their lives haven't improved the average
American feels or their life has not
improved so how can they care about the
problems that you're talking about right
yeah the question is are you willing to
spend a little less than 1% on on saving
lives for a few thousand dollars per
life the European governments are tend
to be about twice as generous on these
eight issues as the United States is so
they're they've set a good example even
the UK making increases but it's a
political decision and and if there's
cynicism at the lack of understanding
that really good things are happening
out there then the voters aren't aren't
going to be willing recently in the
budget compromise polio got an extra
fifty million a year so you know some
progress is being made on something
where we have very clear targets in that
case by 2018 completely eradicating the
disease also it's it's very self-serving
as well if you cure a disease elsewhere
then you're not like
to catch that disease if we live in a
world where diseases can spread very
easily we want stability around the
world that is self-serving because our
safety depends on a world that doesn't
start wars and gets along and there's a
compassionate part of this you don't we
have an obligation to stop genocide and
I think that you come back to right
where we started with this interview
things are better and we can make a
difference
you're not going to cure everything
overnight or even ever but to sit back
and say oh it's hopeless that's not true
it's like one of the things that in
Bill's letter he points out the better
educated people don't over populate the
world quite the contrary a lot of poor
people have lots of kids because they
don't think they'll survive and there's
not going to be a breadwinner down the
road to take care of them and their
dotage and if everybody's healthier it
just leads to a much more rational world
and lets us deal with the real problems
bill you know people know you and know
your work as a philanthropist but they
also know you as the founder of
Microsoft and you're still the chairman
of that company how involved are you on
a day to day basis with Microsoft well
I'm on the board and in the boards doing
some important work right now the
foundation is the biggest part of my
time but then you know I put part-time
work in to help help us a board member
are you involved at all or how involved
are you with with the search for the new
chief executive how the board's working
on that now there's nothing new to say
but you know it's a good board do you
feel a sense of urgency at all the
support there's a board feel a sense of
urgency on this front i I think you'd
always feel that way then again you want
to you know pick the best person so you
know they'll they'll move with the
bright pace you know we have the fortune
of having the mayor come back after this
to this company and we're very happy to
have him back at Bloomberg
our bill has that ever hit in your has
that ever hit your vision in the future
of ever going back to Microsoft
full-time well my full-time work will be
the foundation for the rest of my life
my wife Melinda are enjoying that you
know I I get to do it in depth so I'm
not I'm not going to change that I'll
help out part time might tell me how you
think in the 12 years that you have been
in public office technology the industry
itself has changed dramatically new
pioneers that are following the
footsteps of Bill Gates what do you
what's giving your take on the state of
technology and how well technology is an
enabler technology's a tool but I think
the basics really haven't changed
education business philanthropy is still
about people looking each other in the
eye listening to each other working
collaboratively and collectively and you
got to be very careful and think that
not to think that technology's going to
do everything for you ethics matter
competency the education of our kids is
the most important thing there's
enormous changes in the job prospects
for people at every level and some are
going to lead us down the path with some
very severe problems but nevertheless
the first and most important thing is
every kid getting a good education and
in some parts of the world they
understand that and in some parts of the
world they don't and sadly in America we
don't seem to we keep falling in these
rankings we used to be in the top ten
now we're lucky to be in the top 30 that
does not bode well for our future and
we've just got to pull together get away
from this partisan stuff and start
devoting the resources we need if we're
going to have a future bill you are
passionate as well about training our
young people particularly in computer
science that there's not enough enough
training there yeah I think education is
a topic Mike and I think is incredibly
important and we've been willing to you
know create some controversy saying that
let's help teachers be better let's try
out new approaches the status quos is
pretty unsatisfactory and technology is
going to help particularly for that
motivated learner but how do you create
the motivation broadly
that's mostly a human problem in helping
the teacher do it do it as best possible
and just on a final note bill tell me
what you think about the state of the
technology industry now and how the new
crop of leaders how you how you see them
well the rate of innovation is faster
than ever things like understanding
speech and vision taking large amounts
of data and understanding that big
high-resolution screens that will be on
your walls in the office at home so
we're really in a fantastic period we're
finding information understanding
information is going to get a lot better
and that lead to productivity we can
simulate things so that new product
design and innovation could go faster we
see it in biology even understanding
complex systems and what drugs should be
tried out so I'm a great believer that
whether it's helping the poorest or just
helping the global economy technology
can solve a lot a lot of problems you
just go back and look at what people
predicted a few years ago and they were
so far wrong almost everything they
predicted has been done and yet we in
the next two or three years we will
improve technology more than it was done
from the beginning of inventing
electricity till today Peninsula
exponential and the disruption there's
no industry that's not going to have to
adjust and change some will do it
successfully some won't some people are
going to have better jobs some people
we're going to have to find ways to make
sure that they're included we shouldn't
walk away from it but it is going to be
a very serious problem and it's not just
an American problem it's a problem
around the world it particularly in the
Middle where an awful lot of automation
is taking place that gives you cheaper
better products but it also reemployed
fewer people and we've got to find a
ways to get everybody involved